It's a game changing deal.
I'm just so incredibly proud of what we've achieved.
In a new contract, U.S. soccer women and men's player association's,...
...agreeing to equal pay for all players.
This is just a really historic moment,...
...that will hopefully lead to meaningful changes and progress,...
...not only here at home in the U.S., but around the world.
Both men and women will now get around $450,000 a year,...
...commercial and event revenue will be divvied up.
The team's also shaking hands on sharing World Cup prize money,...
...a first of any soccer organization in the world.
That part of today's agreement is especially notable.
As the women's team clinched the last two World Cups, four overall.
The men haven't won yet,...
...but were still making more money just for playing.
The women's 2015 win netted less than two million dollars,...
...while the men made more than five million dollars,...
...losing in the round of 16 the year before.
That propelled a movement for equal pay captured in the CNN film LFG.
We heard people chanting.
Equal Pay! Equal Pay! Equal Pay!
Oh my gosh.
That's when I felt the movement.
Equal Pay!
All right, it's not just us but, it looks as if the world is on our side.